right now we're in CIA headquarters
which is an underground underground
version of the CIA and we're about three
four five levels down underground and
one of the sets of 24 well we ended
season 8 with Jack Bauer being given a
20-minute window by the president to go
dark or disappear he manages to do that
with the aid of Chloe and he manages to
get out of the country and he has been
hiding in Eastern Europe for the last
four years a threat to the American
president while visiting London in a
conference with the Prime Minister has
brought Jack Bauer from underground to
above-ground where he has now become a
target pretty much every other country
in the world including the United States
and Britain while he's trying to stop
this threat from taking place
this is joint training you're really
something but I was nervous I was very
proud of everything that we had
accomplished in eight years
and there was something very kind of
satisfying about saying okay it's done
but I enjoyed it immensely and and how
it has such a beautiful idea that that
obviously even you would want to be a
part of it but the fear of not having it
fulfill all of its potential is massive
and so it took me a few days of shooting
for me to kind of realize that I felt
very comfortable at home Jon Cassar who
is our lead director was a lead director
producer for all the way up until season
seven and is fantastic to be working
with him right now and shooting in
London has been amazing we've had the
nicest time here I have a phenomenal
crew and as you can see look at our set
my production design is extraordinary
and source yeah right now is perfect
I've never gone through an entire season
224 without getting hurt so you know
I'll make the joke about the age
difference and the bones being a little
more brittle but the reality is if you
do this long enough you're gonna bang a
knee here you know if I fractured my
kneecap I've broken a few different
bones I think I've gotten about 27 lot
stitches over the years stuff happens
you know and and this year is no
exception